when did the american dream go from like
working hard to
just like being handed a million bucks
1970 when nixon took us off the gold
standard no
fiat currency okay come on that's when
the communists
infiltrated american institutions and
have pumped us awful the notion that the
government is supposed to give us
everything when was that
starting in the 50s and the 60s dude it
used
it used to be mccarthy was the right
dream
the american dream actually was upward
mobility
there are certain countries where you're
poor you'll always be poor because
you're not a noble you're not landed
gentry you're not a king it's never
going to happen
you come to america and you could flick
off the president
you could see you could see the
president walking by and go hey
president fu and they can't do anything
about it the american dream was that you
could be gutter trash
and grow up to be a millionaire as long
as you worked hard
and figured it out and that still exists
the problem is it still exists it
happens every day and
at some point millennials especially
figured the american dream was
i do as i'm told i take out massive
loans
i go to college and then i'll be rich it
could have been
the rockefeller movement like he
monopolized and
the education industry and kind of
destroyed people's will to i never went
to business school i didn't know how to
run a business i don't know how to sign
a check till i was 19 years old
i didn't write a check isn't that insane
i've never wrote a check
let me tell you something let me say
something yes i understand what you're
saying jack about
communism and infiltrating schools and
all that stuff and i've heard a lot
about it
we know that china has an interest in
promoting this because the chinese
accounts on twitter this is what james
lindsay was saying they used to they
used to mock the baitswa
the white left that's their words
baitswa also they started supporting
them
saying yeah america's racist because
they realized it was weakening the
country but i'll tell you something
in my experience my anecdotal uh my
personal worldview my lived experience
my lived your viewpoint my personal
point of view
my family i hear i always would hear
these stories growing up about how
someone my family knew was making six
figures
because they went to college and that's
why you have to go to college to get a
good job and i said
not interested and then what i realized
later in life was that
a lot of these people after world war ii
the boomers right they had high school
educations
and they were feeding their family three
kids and a wife just on their high
school education
they made it work granted they didn't
have the same level of technology or
comfort as we did
so you know standard of living was
particularly different
but with a high school education alone i
read about how
the boomer generation people with high
school educations
they were managers at companies they had
jobs they weren't making six figures
they made the false assumption that the
money
came because of the college degree
however
if you grew up at a time where you
didn't need a college degree to be to
succeed and feed your family
but you decided to pursue your passion
what was really happening is that those
were who are most passionate and driven
towards a certain goal decided to go to
college
college was incidental it's a spurious
correlation
the actual correlation is those who are
willing to work hard to attain or
achieve some goal and those who are not
what happens then when your entire
society starts telling all the young
people
college is the key take out forty fifty
sixty thousand dollars of loans you'll
never pay back in a lifetime
you end up with a bunch of angry
indebted
serfs can't find work and think the
american dream was stripped from them
well they were lied to for sure by
society went astray
but these are people who need to be
taught how
hard work can give you the american
dream the only problem is the hard work
they worked towards was a trap
they dug themselves into a massive hole
generated tons of debt
because they were dumb 18 year olds who
didn't know better and because
i blame the older generation stripping
the value
extracting what they can and then we get
financial crisis
chaos and everything's falling apart so
forgive me if i'm a millennial blaming
the older generations but i
look we inherited this stuff from you so
it's not on me i would you're a gen xer
right
represent you get a free pass i'm gen x
as it
gets tim a lot of what you said is
absolutely right
the people that made the most of a
college degree were going to make the
most of life
anyway when they didn't need one though
right the point is
if society tells you you don't need to
go to college and you go yeah but i want
to because i really want to study this
thing
well it's no surprise that this
passionate driven individual became
successful
but you get a bunch of people who are
like you know i remember when i was 18
and they're like you got to go to school
and i'm like for what what do you like
doing i don't
know well how about music you play music
i guess
so what i was going to be an 18 year old
going like oh and then but
but draining tens of thousands of
dollars in debt
that's the stupidest idea i was like i'm
not gonna do that's dumb i don't want to
owe anybody money
i'd rather just like sleep on a couch
and go skating
so it worked out for me i don't got any
debt a lot of people i do have that
that still worked out for me because i
wanted to i wanted to go i wanted to
study acting and it was worth every
penny of it
not for everybody most people change
their majors yeah and end up not getting
a job in their field you got to want it
you got to be good at it you got to be
dedicated to it
you got to live it breathe it focus on
it every second of every day
it is your life that is what you always
tell you what else has it been the
money's subsidiary
you want to know what else college did
you want to know what else it did jack
it took
kids out of their communities and sent
them to far away lands
and then all of a sudden their ties to
the community were fractured
so now you had people growing up and
they weren't going to the water cooler
they weren't going to the churches maybe
they're not religious they weren't going
to the community centers
they weren't engaging in local activism
or local journalism or local politics
they moved away maybe there's a good
thing in that but ultimately it means
our community started breaking apart and
now one of the biggest problems we have
is people are replacing their real
communities with fake online communities
often with sock puppet accounts
and they're looking for some kind of
gratification from online strangers who
have cat avatar profiles or something
or a cat cat anime pictures on their
twitter account that's current but the
future is actually using the internet to
find
real communities a hundred percent it's
happening i'm doing it i won't pitch it
anymore
we gotta bring people to the real world
that's absolutely a hundred percent
tim you're talking about things that
have been in play for decades and
decades and decades and decades now
yeah i mean it's true these ideas were
seriously implanted in our brains back
in the 50s and the 60s and they've now
made their way through the institutions
to the point now where we are a sick
culture of victims
who rank themselves according to how
aggrieved they are
not according to how successful or
accomplished they are or how
realized no actualized that they are
it's actually a detriment to be
successful
right because that's evidence that
you're part of the white supremacy well
that's
that's what they said to me when uh when
i was at occupy wall street
before i got any recognition i had all
these people saying like see look at you
man you know
you dropped out of high school and like
you're a smart guy you should be very
successful but the system doesn't allow
it you know you come from a mixed family
and it's very obvious how it's holding
you back and then all of a sudden i'm
featured in time magazine i'm featured
in all these websites and
they said then tim pool is white and he
was born with a silver spoon in his
mouth
more or less story don't listen to other
people in this re and this
the moral perhaps and the gist of the
story is if you succeed
they will accuse you of being privileged
and always having been privileged
because the idea of hard work doesn't
exist to them exactly
because if you succeed that means
that the only reason they're not
succeeding because they didn't try
yep and that is and that's why the
asians are going to get crushed by the
blacks in this new culture scenario
that's why they're trying to make it
look like there's white on asian
violence happening all over the universe
when there really isn't
this is one of the most the real issue
is that the asian immigrants
are making african-american indigenous
people
look bad do you think that's why the
violence is happening
no that that's the violence is what it
is that guy shot up a bunch of
hookers basically that was like sex
related okay but this idea
we don't know that's true actually it
doesn't it doesn't matter the point is
is that it's not some white supremacist
going on a rampage trying to kill a
bunch of asian ladies
like come on so what's happening here
is that the the the crt folks and the
african-american victim community that
wants to be victims not all of them the
specific community
are saying that we live in an oppressive
society that keeps minorities down
well guess what all these asian folks
are coming from all over not just
far east asia or southeast asia or india
asia but all of those asia parts
they're coming to the united states and
they're out earning white dudes yeah
this actually surprised me because i i
didn't realize
filipinos actually have some of the
highest incomes in the united states
yeah
dude it's the it's it's indian folks
come
asian folks come to united states make
more money than white people why because
it's a meritocratic system
if you're good at something you get paid
for it you can be tim pool
drop out of high school not go to
college become a
you know many thousand there here living
in in wherever we are
but the reason that this conflict is
going to come between the blacks and
asians is because
the asians are just proving the thesis
of black lives matter
false it's not a race thing it's
it is not going to be black people
versus asian people it is going to be
woke people versus asian people sorry
you're right
yeah it's it's so like ellen west
sitting here the other day mentally with
amen to that i'm sorry all those
comments were meant to say
the crt you know social justice
black lives matter folks that are
pitching they're mostly white the
fine all of them are pitching the black
victimhood narrative
that all black suffering is a result of
white systems of oppression which i
heard
chanted over and over again but bro
they're not saying just
black people they're saying a hierarchy
of different races are oppressed by
white people
they used to claim that it was asian
people on top now after this shooting
they're saying asians are actually
oppressed again
so it's it's not about any one race it
is about manipulative
extremist dogmatic cultists who will who
will use whatever narrative they have to
gain power
sometimes they'll talk about black lives
matter but they'll use the communist
fist as their symbol
sometimes they'll blame asians because
you've got that one woman
i'm not going to say her name but james
lindsay's been tweeting up a storm about
her where she was like
well you see the asians who came here
chose to come here in the early
you know early american history they
weren't forced to do it
then after this wave of violence they
say now they're being now she's tweeting
they were forced to come here actually
it was indentured servitude
it's like oh okay you never cared about
these people you manipulate
these people it doesn't matter if you're
asian latino hispanic black or whatever
all they want to do
is pit one group against the other to
gain power
so they're going to use victimhood amen
and they're going to say
these people are oppressing us and you
know what's funny they accused trump of
being the demagogue
they said he was the one who was
vilifying different groups of people
sure there were certain instances where
trump said some things like you know he
wanted to ban all muslims
donald trump literally said that he was
calling for a ban on muslims until they
can figure things out
eventually what they called the muslim
ban came to include a couple other
countries like venezuela and north korea
so it wasn't
exclusively a muslim ban or contain all
the muslim countries
right it didn't it didn't include saudi
arabia you know indonesia
right america muslims the point was
donald trump certainly had his bombastic
demigogory type language but they are
built upon it and have been for a decade
trump was a response to it at the
creation of it amen when they kept
coming out in the early
you know late 2009 early 2010s screaming
about white privilege
racism systemic racism white people and
you can see in in the alexis nexus data
the hockey stick of the new york times
just
screaming about white privilege then you
got
what they were calling the white lash a
backlash but white people were now
saying enough of this already
the funny thing is we were taught
growing up
segregation is wrong people should be
treated equally it was the dream of dr
king that all people
would be treated based on the content of
their character and the color of their
skin
and which party is fighting that tooth
and nail
the democratic party joe biden's
department of education
just rescinded a rule that said
racial affinity groups was
discriminatory that rule's gone now that
was a trump rule trump said you can't do
this you can't separate people at
schools based on race
biden's administration no no you can do
that again congratulations columbia
university just said
graduations by race that's right
by race now what's funny is at the end
of the day you're right there's going to
be one small group of people over here
the woke
and there's going to be a huge coalition
of diversity
over here opposing woke and in fact the
opposing racial justice people
will be more diverse than the group
saying that they're you know the woke
folks and the irony is
it's not going to be african-americans
in the middle of that it may end up
amanda being black trans women or
whatever but
but truly all of this is is suburban
white yes liberal women that's right
this entire thing
is about suburban white liberal women
their guilt their their interest in
destroying the patriarchy
they're lying supinely on the ground
begging
for acceptance and forgiveness and
they're willing to throw their entire
country away
just so that they won't be called a
racist when they haven't been one
they aren't one and they've just taken
this identity
on for themselves uh i did an interview
with arthur millick the head
of the center for the american way of
life in washington to see a clermont
east
operation and he pointed out that even
the ancient texts
the classics they talk about the demise
of a society is when it's
run on the whim and fancy of single
women
that is what we have today the entire
nation
all of our political discourse all this
woke crap all this
everything is based on trying to appease
the this power of
single white liberal women and you know
what's funny half of guys
are just doing what those women tell
them of course because what do they want
they want the women
right no they're just saying so they'll
do whatever yeah thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you